comme à chaque année pêches et océans
canada fait le bilan des conditions
observées dans saint laurent dont la
température de l'eau en 2021 on a
atteint des records très préoccupant
[Musique]
pour les vacanciers l'été l'automne 2000
21 ont été impeccables mais pour les
eaux du saint-laurent ces vagues de
chaleur successives il a bien fallu les
absorber non seulement loup est devenu
plus chaudes mais les demeurer plus
longtemps
les anomalies de températures plus
élevées en rouge montre que les autres
surfaces du golfe et de l'estuaire n'ont
jamais été aussi chaude pour les mois
d'octobre et novembre
en quarante ans de données
si la chaleur accumulée l'automne
dernier dans les autres surfaces a
disparu avec le froid intense du début
de l'année 2022 c'était tout le
contraire l'hiver passé
[Musique]
l'hiver 2021 a été vraiment d'où la
glace étaient rares et il est apparu
tard
d'ailleurs depuis 1970 les volumes de
glaces tend à diminuer
particulièrement depuis des 12 dernières
années
cette masse d'eau en surface plus chaude
qu'à l'habitude durant l'hiver dernier a
contribué plus tard en saison à
réchauffer à son tour la couche d'eau
qui se situe juste en dessous en 2021 la
température de cette couche d'eau
intermédiaire a aussi grimpé
jamais elle n'a été aussi chaude depuis
40 ans même constat dans les profondeurs
du saint laurent
tributaire des courants océaniques
la température de l'eau à 300 mètres de
profondeur a grimpé à plus de 6 degrés
celsius dans l'estuaire et même plus le
salir dans le golfe jamais en cent ans
la température à cette profondeur n'aura
été aussi élevé qu'en 2021
[Musique]